[Music]
thanks for the very nice introduction
Sebastian so I wish I could be out there
in Cambridge with you pretend
participate in the summer school but
unfortunately I'm not very good with jet
lag so I decided to stay home for this
one so this tutorial is going to be this
is going to be a policy gradient
tutorial which is closely related to the
distort tutorial that Peter Beal and I
gave at nips this last year but with
some modifications and it's actually
going to be fairly basic and just
introduce the basics of policy gradients
have between strategies natural policy
gradient but actually I think the basics
go a really long way for these
algorithms so so I hope I hope it's
beneficial for all of you so before I
get into the details of some of these
algorithms that I'm going to talk about
I'll go I want to just put them in
context a little bit with the other
algorithms from deep reinforcement
learning so so the deep reinforcement
learning is just reinforcement learning
where you're using neural networks as
your function approximator z' and the
one interesting thing is that in
reinforcement learning there there are
several different choices of what to
approximate so this contrasts with say
supervised learning where you just want
to approximate your conditional
probability distribution or something
that so in in reinforcement learning
there are several reasonable choices you
could try to approximate a policy which
is your function that chooses the next
action you could try to approximate a
value function which which is a function
that tells you how good a certain state
is or a certain state action Paris or
you could try to learn the dynamics
model which predicts the knack state and
the reward you then plug into a planning
algorithm so here in this in this talk
I'm going to focus on learning policies
and but I would say that this there's
sort of a taxonomy of different methods
that that sort of live in this space so
on the one hand you can directly
optimize policies and one way to do that
with is with derivative free
optimization or also known as
evolutionary algorithms where you just
you try to optimize over the parameter
vector without using anything about the
actual trajectories generated from that
parameter vectors so you just you're
just treating the whole environment as a
black box where you put in a parameter
vector and you get a return then there
are these policy grading methods which
use which actually take advantage of the
temporal structure of the problem and
try to figure out which were the good
actions in which was a bad actions let's
make the good actions probably let's
adjust our action so that they're better
so that's sort of what we've got on the
policy optimization side and dynamic
programming is another class of
algorithms that are based on learning
value functions and in the so there's
there's a set of classic algorithms that
will exactly solve an MDP where you have
access to all of the information about
the transition probabilities and reward
function so there's these algorithms
that you might have learned about in
that in an elementary course policy
iteration and value iteration which will
exactly solve for the optimal policy and
the value function for an MDP and it's
possible to come up with approximate
versions of these algorithms so that's
that's another class of methods there
and q-learning is sort of an approximate
version of or DQ n DQ learning is sort
of an approximate very than a value
iteration but we're focused here on in
this in this talk I'm going to focus on
the policy optimization methods and well
first what's what's the difference
between them in empirically and and also
sort of conceptually well the one big
advantage of the policy optimization
methods is you're optimizing the thing
you care about which is the expected
return of the policy in contrast the
dynamic programming methods are more
indirect they try to exploit the problem
structure to learn a value function
using self-consistency property that the
value function should have specifically
that the value function now should be
consistent with the value function at
the next time step so so they can be so
that's there's a slight mismatch between
what what's in your loss function which
is this consistency condition and what
you actually care about which is the
expected return but empirically what
happens is the policy optimization
methods are a bit more versatile meaning
they tend to work in more situations
whereas the dynamic programming methods
are more sample efficient when they do
work this is just a very rough
assessment of the empirical results and
and the jury's still out on which
methods are going to work the best in
the long run but this is just the
current state of things and also the
policy optimization methods are more
compatible with with richer function
approximator z-- such as recurrent
neural networks and also architectures
that add auxiliary objectives such as
making predictions in addition to
control
so that's sort of the that's the
advantage of the policy optimization of
methods whereas they did dynamic program
methods are more compatible with off
policy learning and in turn that makes
them more compatible with exploration
because to do our exploration you often
want to collect data from a policy that
other than the one that's your current
best guess of the optimal policy okay so
that's that's just an overview of where
a policy optimization methods sit
relative to the other methods but now so
now I'm going to get more into the
details and set up what the problem is
and more precisely so we're going to be
concerned with parametrized policies and
what that means is you have a policy
that's a family of policies that's index
with some parameter vector which in this
case is just a vector of real numbers
and this could either be a deterministic
policy where that the action is a
deterministic function of the state and
the parameter vector or you could have a
stochastic policy where you have a
condition where the action is a
conditional probability distribution
that depends on the state and the
parameter vector and this is totally
analogous to classification or
regression where the state is your input
and the action is your output and you
can use the exact same kind of function
approximator that you'd use in
classification or regression for example
if your reinforcement learning problem
has a discrete action space you can take
a network architecture that would have
been used for classification where your
network outputs affect your
probabilities whereas if you have a
continuous action space you can use a
network that you would have used for
regression where the network can be
interpreted as outputting a mean and
it's a diagonal covariance matrix for a
Gaussian
also in the for the purposes of this
talk we're going to be concerned with
the episodic reinforcement learning
setting there are actually several
different ways you can set up the
optimization problem and in when it
comes down to the algorithms it actually
doesn't matter that much since the
algorithms look basically the same but
we're going to be most concerned with
the Wisconsin at Masonic setting where
where the we have an agents whose
experience is broken up into a series of
episodes each of which has a finite
number of times deficits so in each
episode you sample in an initial state
from some distribution mu and the Asian
accent so it reaches a certain terminal
state at which point the episode ends
just to give you a few examples of what
an episode might look like let's say you
have a taxi robot and the other state is
when it reaches its destination
so then termination is good and we want
the episodes to terminate as fast as
possible you might also have a situation
where the episode has a fixed length and
you just try to accumulate as much
reward as possible during that fixed
amount of time so that would be like a
waiter robot finishing where the episode
ends is when it finishes its shift or
you could have another kind of MVP where
you want the episode to be as long as
possible like you have a walking robot
and you want it to be able to stand up
as long as possible or stay up as long
as possible before falling over so the
goal in this setting is to maximize the
expected reward per episode so we're
going to use capital R to denote the
return which is to be distinguished from
the the reward which so the reward
corresponds to a single time step where
the return corresponds to of all
episodes so reward will be lowercase R
and return is capital R and we're
concerned with maximizing the expected
reward that you get the expected return
which is the sum of reward in it the
whole episode so there are various ways
of optimizing this expected return and
first I mean to talk about what's sort
of conceptually the simplest way to do
it which is with derivative free
optimization and the idea here is you
put in a parameter you have your
parameter vector which defines your
policy and between everything says it's
a black box so so actually what's
happening inside the black box is here
there's a series of time steps and each
time step you're sampling an action and
then generating next state and reward
but we're going to ignore all that and
just say we put the parameter into that
black box get a return which is
stochastic and use that information to
try to adjust our parameter vector so so
the first I'm going to talk just
introduced and how agree them called the
cross entropy method which is simple to
understand intuitively and that will
give you an intuition for why these
what's kind of going on in these
derivative free optimization methods and
then I'll talk a little bit more about
how to justify it but first just to
introduce the algorithm are this the
main state is here meaning the our
current our current estimate about the
parameter vector vehicle parameters is
stored in two vectors we have a vector
mean nasty BH rich parameter so we're
that means we have a Gaussian with
diagonal covariance over parameters and
what we're going to do is iteratively
improve this distribution over
parameters so each iteration what we do
is first we collect and samples and
random parameters by sampling from this
Gaussian distribution then for each
parameter vector we perform one episode
with it by that means we just run our
policy for one episode until the episode
terminates and that gives us a return
that's a typo should say return capital
R then after we've done these n episodes
we take the top P percent where P is a
hyper
this algorithm we take the top P percent
like putting the top 20% which now we
fit a new Gaussian distribution to the
elite set and update mu and Sigma that
means so fitting it that just means
usually we do maximum likelihood of that
buoyed set so this I mean if if you're
if you are familiar with evolutionary
algorithms this will this would be a
kind of familiar structure where you
have a certain population which is
defined by a Gaussian distribution and
then you take you pick the members of
the population that have highest fitness
and you you fit a new distribution to
those highly fit members of the
population and then you repeat the
process again so so it sort of makes
sense that you're you're just moving
your distribution towards the good parts
of parameter space over time and so you
doing this for a while and then at the
very ends after you've done all of your
iterations you return the final mean
parameter which is your which is your
best estimate for the optimal parameter
so this is this simple algorithm is
called well well it's the culling across
the tree method for sort of rhetorical
reasons which is that it's it's related
to its it's actually a method it was
derived for for something else for
integral estimation but actually I won't
go into the details for that but the
funny thing is sometimes if this
algorithm works embarrassingly well and
in particular there's so the game of
tetris has for a long time been a
benchmark tasks in reinforcement
learning or in approximate dynamic
programming just sort of means the same
thing as reinforcement learning and so a
lot of so this table is taken from the
paper learning test for tetris using the
noisy cross-country method and it shows
that there were several previous papers
that use reinforced
learning techniques to play Tetris and
they got certain scores that are in the
low of thousands and but then so the
it's not the better performing the best
performance is obtained by this hands
coded policy or by genetic algorithms
and as a turn which both of which
there's a lot of hands engineering in
both of these cases and this pay the
paper that this table is taken from
showed that you just use the cross
entropy method it's you get a really
high score which is competitive with the
the best performance obtained by these
kind of hands crafted methods and you
get much better results than any of the
the reinforcement learning methods and I
think we're so in particular methods
that are based on policy iteration and
policy gradients so these are those when
I say reinforcement learning methods I
mean methods that exploit the fact that
you're trying to solve an FTP and try to
take advantage of the temporal structure
of the problem so I think the reason why
this happens is because chrome century
meant it is is optimizing well mostly
optimizing the right thing which is the
performance of the parameter vector over
many thousands of time steps that it
takes in an episode where as the
reinforcement learning methods have to
make some approximations so even though
they're exploiting the structure of the
problem they end up approximating the
wrong thing in particular they have to
introduce what's called a discount
factor where you ignore you sort of
ignore long term dependencies and I
think that's probably what kills them
but you don't need to worry about a
discount factor with the cross entry
method I'm going to talk about the
discount factor shortly but so so anyway
a couple years a few years ago there's a
paper showing the u by being really
careful
you approximate your value function you
actually can get the good results on
Tetris using approximate dynamic
programming but I think I still think
it's sort of a win for Crescent entropy
because of how simple the algorithm is
and how it works pretty well without
that much tuning so so I didn't really
justify the cross entry method though it
sort of makes sense intuitively but now
I'm going to talk about a very closely
related approach which can be
mathematically derived pretty
straightforwardly which is to do
stochastic gradient descent on your the
parameters of your distribution and
shortly I'll show how cross entry method
is closely related to this shortly but
so the idea here is in every method we
have this Gaussian distribution and
we're interative Li moving this Gaussian
distribution to give better and better
returns so can we just do stochastic
gradient descent because to consecrating
is a sense of this these distribution
parameters so that's what we're gonna do
here and when we select let's say that
we we defined this to reuse this
distribution P sub mu over our our
policy parameters so in this case mu
well Mew could be the mean of a Gaussian
or it could be the mean and the standard
deviation let's pretend for now we're
just optimizing over the B and then
we're gonna pick standard deviation and
the same method can be used to adjust
the standard deviation but usually
that's not very useful anyway so let's
just say we're optimizing over the mean
of a Gaussian distribution so the return
depends on the policy parameter and some
noise so let's just say we've we've
defined everything so that the return is
a deterministic function of the
parameter vector theta and some noise
Zeta so now our optimization problem can
be written
follow us we have we're maximizing over
mu of the expectation of our return
where the reward is I mean where the
parameter theta is sampled according to
this distribution so well this is a
little bit nuts straightforward because
our return is unknown and it's possibly
not differentiable so we don't know this
function R and it's probably not a nice
and smooth function of the parameter
vector theta so I mean especially let's
say we have just a discrete action space
then clearly our isn't going to be a
deterministic function of our policy
parameter so so it's kind of non obvious
that we can even do this so that we can
even differentiate this but as it turns
out we can and it's a very basic and
important technique called the score
function grading estimator also known as
the likelihood ratio estimator and the
way it looks is the grading of this
expectation equals the expectation of
log grad log probability times return so
so we've just what we've done here is
we've just I mean the idea of a grading
estimator is you want to get you're
trying to has to make the gradient of
this expectation and we want to write
that as an expectation of something
which we can then compute we can get a
Monte Carlo estimate of so here we can
get we can get our Monte Carlo estimate
by just collecting a bunch of samples
and then taking for each sample we take
grad log probability times return and we
take the empirical average of those okay
so i'll derive this in a sec but before
I share eyes that let's just look at the
relationship between the score function
grading estimator and what we were doing
in the cross entropy that so
your score function grading estimator
we've got grant log probability times
return whereas in the cross entry method
we have an objective that we optimize
each iteration I actually didn't write
this in the algorithm the pseudocode but
the way we fit the Gaussian distribution
to our data points is we do maximum
likelihood or we maximize the log
probability of our elite set under the
parametrized distribution so what that
means is so what we have here is if we
if we look at all of our samples not
just the elite set what we have is a log
probability of the sample times some
function of the return and in this case
what we did in the cross entry method is
we just took the indicator that that
return R was above threshold so we would
see the 0 or 1 and so you can see that
if we if we got rid of this threshold in
function f then the objective were
maximizing the each batch in each
iteration of crossbencher P is same as
the objective we've differentiated with
the score function grading estimator so
you can see that they're going to do
similar updates but maybe the kresson
our method will - will be able to take a
bigger step each iteration because it
you don't have to just take a single
gradient step actually another
illuminating connection is between the
score function grading estimator and
between doing finite differences so it
turns out that the score from Canadian
estimator is very similar to doing
towards another kind of an intuitive
algorithm that involves taking a random
direction in doing a directional
derivative in that direction and then
doing the gradient step using that
directional derivative so so I'll show
you that this core function grading
estimator comes out to be this almost
the same it's a certain kind of
directions by a difference so to see
that let's just compute
explicitly what happens with their score
function gradient estimator in the
gaussian case where we're optimizing
over the mean at the gaussian so so
here's our log probability and then when
we take the gradient of the log
probability so it's just parameter minus
mean over standard deviation squared and
then so here's our estimator reward
times the parameter minus the mean okay
so it doesn't look so illuminating yet
but now let's say we do antithetic
sampling so if you have a symmetric
distribution such as a gaussian you can
compute your expectation you can get an
equivalent it's the same expectation by
collecting two samples at a time where
you collect a given you collect a random
sample from your distribution and then
the name of that sample or the the
mirror image of that sample around the
center of this distribution so this is
just a general kind of Monte Carlo
estimation technique it's called an
effete example so here what we do each
step we take a pair of samples mean plus
noise times so noise time standard
deviation and mean minus times standard
deviation here Z is from normal 0 1
meaning mean 0 standard deviation I mean
variance is the identity and Sigma is
this is our daya I mean our our vector
of standard deviations so this is an
element-wise product or you can just
consider this counter case for now if
you don't want to worry about vectors so
anyway when we so if we write it what
we're going to do here is write down the
score function grading estimator but
where you use antithetic sampling so you
got two samples at it's time so I'm
writing an average or two syllables
we have rewards at blend Sam I mean
return at once ample minus return at the
other sample times are
see which is our our noise which is just
normal 0 1 so so what we have here is we
have Z as effectively just a random
direction because we just sampled a
random vector and and then we look at
the return measured at correct like mean
plus Z and mean minus Z scale
appropriately so we have our so this is
just our finite difference and we're
dividing by the like the length or the
size of the perturbation Sigma so here
this is just our directional derivative
and then we're multiplying it by the
random direction that the recruitment is
taken in so so this is a kind of
intuitive algorithm sometimes called
these perturbations to Casting
approximation it's not exactly I don't
know there I want to get into specifics
of that but but this is a kind of
intuitive algorithm and it's and you can
see that it's exactly what you get by
doing the score function grading
estimator with antithetic sampling and
oh yeah so if you use different noise
samples to do both function evaluations
then you're going to have you could
potentially have a lot of arrogance
because because it could be that most of
the signal most of the difference
between these returns is coming from the
noise and it's not coming from the
difference in parameter so so you ends
up having a an error term that goes like
1 over Sigma so if you have a very small
Sigma and you used two different noise
samples then you're gonna get a pretty
bad estimate but it is the same noise
samples so if Zeta equals a 2 prime here
then you get a much better estimate
because
what happens is your well under almost
all conditions these two terms are going
to be positively correlated so meaning
when you when you take an expectation
over Zeta these terms are going to be
like very positively correlated so if we
take the difference of them wear any
Canada as well add some of the noise
that comes from Zeta so anyway we get
much lower variance if we're able to
like freeze the noise and so so we can
if we have access to a simulator for
example then we can use the same random
seed and evaluate two different
parameter vectors from that angle speed
of course in the real world we can't do
that okay so that's that's that's
basically that's sort of three different
views on during a free optimization and
we have these kind of similar similar
algorithms that we get I'll just quickly
show how you derive the score function
gradient estimator in case you haven't
seen this before so this is what this is
the estimator that I wrote on the
previous slide so you can just derive it
by writing the expectation as an
integral and then you just swap you just
swap the integral in the gradient and
you can do that whenever the probability
distribution is continuous actually it
doesn't even have to be differentiable
it just has to be almost everywhere
differentiable so as long as it's almost
everywhere differentiable you can swap
this grow on the derivative and and then
you get this yes so then then what you
have to do is you use so by the chain
rule when you take grad block
probability that's equal to grad
probability
/ probability so what we've done here
going from equation 2 to equation 3 here
is we've just multiplied and divided by
the probability density and and then we
pulled the okay so then the reason we
did that is though so we can turn the
unit growth back into it expectation
because we need to have some probability
measure multiplying the the integrand so
so we turn it back into an expectation
and now we get this expectation of grad
log probability times return so that's
okay that's my overview on the
derivative free optimization there are
several different versions the switcher
so actually the the algorithm where you
where you do random Direction finite
differences and you use you to
stochastic grading a set with that is
usually called evolution strategies and
this is from the 70's and it's also
related to this SPSA algorithm so
Crescent entropy method has become
pretty popular for applications where
you have a fairly small number of
parameters and there's actually another
version of it which is even more popular
called covariance matrix adaptation
where instead of using the diagonal
covariance to use a full covariance
matrix but there are also some other
tricks which help out to get a better
estimate of this full matrix because
otherwise you wouldn't be able to
estimated from a single patch so CM a
covariance matrix at occasion is a way
of Lee updating your covariance matrix
and this is very effective in some in a
lot of problems where you have this
fairly small number of parameters and
this these are also pretty closely
related to some algorithms that are more
can sort of that have been more focused
on the
robotics or reinforcement learning
setting it's a reward weighted
regression and the power algorithms so
CMA has actually been very popular and
successful for optimizing locomotion
controllers in for simulated robots and
also a little bit for real robots but I
won't go into that so so for example
there's this long-running challenge of
playing soccer robot soccer which is
found in simulation and in the real
world but the leading teams in sebacean
in the simulation league what they do is
they they optimize a bunch of
controllers for walking and for getting
up off the ground by first first they
parameterize this controller so they
they have some kind of 20 parameter
thing which which is like a trajectory
which is going to be followed with PID
where you have to tune a bunch of
targets and games for PID controllers so
they they parameterize this thing some
kind of trajectory and then they use
CMAs optimizes over the parameters and
they they do this for walking and
getting up and so on so and then they
use CMA to optimize this parameter V and
it's also used for optimizing locomotion
controllers more in the context of
computer graphics where you're trying to
get physically realistic walking
controllers so it's been quite
successful in this kind of application
so recently there's been there's a
recent paper showing that evolution
strategies performs pretty well on the
atari benchmark which has been used for
deep reinforcement learning so so the
previously cue learning and policy
grading methods has been shown to do
well on Atari and Solomons that all
showed that if you just use evolutions
rata G's using the same kind of network
which was used for policy gradients it
actually gives competitive performance
it might be a little bit worse in terms
of sample complexity but but actually
well it's much easier to paralyze so and
yeah so it might have advantages in some
cases and it's also not as us
sensitive to certain it doesn't require
as many sort of approximations as policy
grading methods where you have to worry
about like skin frame skip as it's about
where you have to repeat actions for
multiple frames otherwise it doesn't
learn very well or and policy grading
methods you also have to worry about you
have to introduce discount factors so
the nice thing about evolution
strategies is or the blackboxes
optimization approach is you don't have
to you don't have to worry about the
time horizon as much you don't have to
worry about what's called credit
assignment where you kind of figure out
which actions were responsible for the
rewards since you're just directly
optimizing in parameter space okay so
that's that's it for evolution
strategies on I would stop for questions
but I'm not sure if it's going to work
very well because I can't see everyone
and I'm not sure your mic their
microphones that's where if I'd be able
to hear you okay yeah yeah then why
don't we why don't I did I'll just open
it up if anyone has any questions before
we go on to the next section
okay ready for the next section great
okay so on to policy grading methods
okay so the problem we're trying to
solve again is to optimize the expected
reward of the expected return of a
parametrized policy and what we're going
to do here in the policy for policy
grading methods is we're going to have a
policy parameter theta which is which
which is fixed at any given point in the
algorithm and we updated over time but
instead of keeping track of a
distribution over policy parameters
we're going to have a single core policy
parameter at any given time and we're
going to estimate the gradient of the
this expectation with respect to the
policy parameter so one way to think
about this is now our noise is in action
space instead of in parameter space so
the intuition of what we're going to do
is we collect a bunch of trajectories
used in our parameterize policy and well
there's three different ways of thinking
of it which are all correct and
correspond to slightly different kinds
of methods one is we try to make the
good trajectories more probable so if we
do that we don't have to worry about the
individual actions we just have one
whole trajectory and we're trying to
make the good ones more probable than
the bad ones less probable okay then
what we can try to do to get better
policy grading estimates is figure out
which actions were good and which ones
are bad and then we try to make the good
actions more probable and the bad
actions less probable and then there's a
third class of methods which actually
try to if you have these only really
make sense if you have a continuous
action space and these methods will try
to push your actions towards slightly
better actions so so you try to estimate
the these require some kind of a
function which will tell you how good a
given action is and it'll push that
towards a better action so
I don't think I'm gonna have time to get
into those but that's another
interesting class of methods so so now
I'll get into how you actually do that
mathematically and the way it works is
to just we're gonna use the same kind of
score function grading estimator that we
used in the derivative free optimization
setting except now our random variable
instead of being a policy parameter is
the whole trajectory I mean remember how
I said that the noise now is in project
is in action space or a trajectory space
rather than parameter space so now our
random variable is the whole trajectory
so if we just go through the motions to
derive for the score function estimator
we we get we get a perfectly good
estimator here which says that the
grading of the expected return is just
the expectation of grad log of
probability of the trajectory times the
return of the trajectory which is just
recall art return is just the sum of
rewards so so okay that's not so useful
by itself because we've got this
probability of a whole trajectory and by
the way it's worth just it's worth
talking at this point about which which
variables or which quantities are
assumed to be known and which ones are
not known um
when we're trying to run our algorithm
so which parts so for example I mean you
have to assume I've just written down
this optimization problem but I haven't
said anything about which whether we
know what the MVP parameters are and and
so on so do we know what the transition
probabilities are and do we know if the
reward function is or are these things
quantity that we have to activate so
we're going to be interested here in the
setting that we don't know what the
transition probabilities are and we
don't know what the reward function is
and that's but we have to learn anyway
so so our learning algorithm effective
has to either learn these quantities or
somehow just learn the policy without
having access to those quantities so
actually it's worth just appreciating
that well this is kind of non-trivial
but even if you have this problem with
all sorts of unknown quantities that we
can still optimize the policy for it
even though we don't know what the
dynamics model is which which is which
sits inside of this expectation because
it determines what our trajectories are
going to be so it's just worth noting
that this is quite different from the
regime we're in with with other kinds of
machine look most other machine learning
problems not bandit problem so bandit
problems um you have this unknown
distribution of returns from the
different artists but something like
supervised learning usually you have a
finite set of training data but given
your training data you have analytic
access to the full the objective you're
trying to maximize so you can compute
gradients of your objective and even
second derivatives and so on but here we
don't have access to the whole objective
we don't have analytic access to this
expectation that we're trying to
optimize it has quantities in it that we
don't we don't know so if we're so when
we write out the probability of the
trajectory we can just use the chain
rule probabilities to write it as a
product of the probability of the
initial state you have s naught times
the probability the product over time of
probability of action times probability
of next data per board so okay so we
know the probability we have access to
this part the probability of action
given state and parameter vector because
the policy is part of our agent this is
this is what we're learning so so we can
take derivatives
and so forth this but we don't know what
the transition probabilities are we
don't know what the initial state
distribution is so so that's that would
be trouble if we were just trying to
that's a that's going to cause trouble
or alliances somehow analytically
evaluate this expectation but we could
of course do Monte Carlo estimates of it
and that's that's what we have to do so
okay so when we take the log of this
probability it turns the product into a
sum and then we take the log the
creating of this log probability and now
all of the terms that don't depends on
PHA that drop out of this expression so
so that's nice because all the terms
that we just disappeared and and then
we're left with I mean then just
plugging that back into our estimator
formula we get the following
we have expectation over trajectories of
return times the gradient of the sum of
log probabilities so so this formula
okay so let me let's just look at this
formula for a second this formula means
that you so you can get a Monte Carlo
estimate of the expected return by
taking a bunch of trajectories
generating a bunch of trajectories and
then for each one we take the return of
that trajectory and then we multiplied
probability of all the actions along
those trajectories and we multiplied
return times grad log probability and
that gives us our empirical estimate of
the policy gradient and the
interpretation is this a high return
sometimes we're going to get a low
return we want to maximize the log
probability of the samples that have a
high return so we're going to move our
distribution over to like put more
probability mass on those samples so
probability density on those half
okay so that's that's the most crude
kind of grading estimator we can get so
what we can do now is try to derive
lower variance grading estimators so
we're going to get we're going to get
this I mean an estimator that has the
same mean but it's going to have lower
variance so it's going to be a better
estimator and it's going to require
fewer samples to get a good good
estimate so so the way we do that is we
can run through the exact same argument
to get the grading estimator for a
single reward term so so in the previous
slide we were trying to get the great
grad expectation of the sum of rewards
now we're just going to get grad
expectation of a single reward so grad
expectation of this R sub t prime so
just doing the motions we did that it's
equal to R sub T prime times the sum of
grad log probabilities of the preceding
actions because the past action I mean
we can the past actions are equity with
effect this reward at all so we don't
need to worry about the subsequent
actions so okay so that then we want to
get the grand expectation of the sum of
rewards capital R so we just sum this
formula over T prime sorry I said sum it
over to Emmett sum it over T prime so
okay so that leaves us soon you just do
the bookkeeping there and what we get is
the sum of rewards of t prime times the
ground sum of grad log probability of
proceeding actions or you can rearrange
it to be grad log permeability times sum
of six sum of print the rewards after
that action so some of the following
rewards so the interpretation of this
formula is if you get a high rewards
you should that means that you're
perceiving actions for goods so you
should make them more probable this
formula says that if you if for a given
action if the sum of following rewards
were high then we should increase the
probability of that action and these
formulas it's just a trivial
rearrangement of the the sum it's just
bookkeeping to switch between these two
formulas so this is a better estimate of
the policy gradient which respects
causality now we can reduce the variance
okay so the name begain is its reduction
because the policy gradient is what we
care about and now we just want to get
estimated as well as possible as fast as
possible which means reducing the
variance as much as possible of our
estimator so so the best variance I mean
the one really good marys reduction
technique is to introduce what's called
a baseline so the intuition behind the
baseline is
let's okay in their previous formula we
have let's look at the last formula
we've got rad log probability of the
actions times the sum of following
rewards so if we get if we make an
empirical estimate of this we're going
to adjust the probability of every
single action we performed in there our
sample trajectories to try to increase
it let me scale it again so we collect a
bunch of trajectories then we compute we
plug those trajectories into this
formula and so that means we take grad
log probability of each action times the
sum of following rewards and we take
that gradient ascent step so that means
we're increasing the probability of oh
sorry and let's say all of our rewards
are positive but let's just suppose
they're positive in a certain problem
that then we're our gradients
he's going to try to increase the
probability of every single action we
just took but that seems that seems like
a bad idea because some of the actions
were good and some of them were bad
about half of them were good and half of
them were bad so so the idea behind the
baseline is we want to only increase the
probability of an action if it was
better than expected so only about half
of the actions were better than expected
so we should only increase the
probability of the good ones so so now
instead of just multiplying travel by
probability by this following rewards we
do the sum of hunger world's bias some
baseline where the baseline was the
estimate of rogue hope will turn out to
be a good choice for the baseline is the
expected return before taking that
action so okay so one nice fact is that
for any choice of baseline the creating
estimator we get is unbiased and that's
I won't show the derivation on in this
slideshow but it's pretty easy to derive
by just looking at well it turns out
that the if you take the expectation of
grad log probability where we're
sampling from PI this expectation comes
out to zero and you can see that yeah
that's sort of a well-known fact and
it's easy to derive but so so many the
choice of baseline that we plug in here
is going to not introduce bias and it
turns out that a near optimal choice to
plug in here is just the expected return
conditions on the state S sub T and
intuitively that's because we only want
to increase the probability of action C
if the returns that you got here were
better than expected so that means we
should plug in the expected return here
so actually it turns out this isn't the
optimal choice that
as variants the optimal choice actually
involves some kind of weighted estimate
of the return but as it turns out it's
near optimal and it's as good as for all
practical purposes it's the best you're
going to do so and you can also another
way to derive this is to just write out
the I mean the formula for the variance
so the variance of X of some random
variable X is just expectation of x
squared my minus the expectation of x
squared so if you if you write that out
and you make some approximations about
things being independent then you'll
find that you just want to minimize the
you want to minimize the expectation of
this term squared of sum of rewards -
baseline squared so that means you
should just you should just take this
baseline to be the mean of this quantity
or the best possible estimate of this
quantity so that's that's a very power
like useful and powerful variance
reduction technique and that'll get you
a lot of mileage they practice the other
technique that gets you a lot of mileage
is to introduce discounts am i doing the
time by the way does this session that
actually ends now and ten minutes okay
okay good I'll finish up in the next ten
minutes okay a method that's going to
give you a lot of mileage is to
introduce a discount factor so so so far
I haven't added any discount factors but
and as I said before work I've been
talking about the episodic setting where
you just care about the sum of her words
over a full episode sometimes if you
read reinforcement learning books you'll
see a different kind of problem setting
where where you're actually optimizing a
discounted sum of rewards
and I think this is a reasonable thing
to do but often the time horizon you
care about is very long so for example
you might care about well in these
Tetris in this that Tetris benchmark I
was talking about earlier the game might
take a million time steps so that means
you're if you wanted a discount factor
that actually include all those steps
and cancel on them with you it would
need to be very it needs to be point
nine nine nine nine nine nine right so
so anyway what the discount factor is is
its so it sits down waits the effect of
future rewards so so I didn't sorry I
didn't explain in reinforcement learning
textbooks but you sometimes see is you
care about the sum of reward times just
R sub T times gamma to the T so the
problem with that is that if is that
that that's basically going to ignore
all rewards that are far into the future
so I think that this like problem
setting doesn't know it doesn't usually
make sense and I think it makes more
sense to think about the discount factor
as a variance reduction parameter or
birds at least in the policy grading
context what it does is it gives you
them by and buries it off so so what we
can do so the way we're going to
introduce the discount factor here you
want me to modify that our previous
formula for the policy gradient by
introducing the discount factor so
recall that our previous formula when we
have this summer rewards - baseline so
here we're just going to modify it to be
sum of rewards multiply it by this
discount factor minus baseline so this
discount factor you can see that the
discount factor is
um measures the difference in time
between this reward and the action
you're looking at so it's based on the
assumption that the action only affects
rewards in the near future but after
that the effect of this action is washed
out and it's not going to they think we
can measure whether this act was too
good or at finally we can have the next
by looking at some short horizon after
the action but the system kind of
forgets the effect of that action after
a while and okay so if we use this
discount fact factor then if we want to
then by the same arguments areas
providing before we want the baseline to
be the expected discounted summer
rewards so that we can maximally reduce
variance and the way you can also think
about this discount factor as it's it's
doing credit assignment by assuming that
the action deserves no credit for
rewards that are far into the future
Tom so if your discount factor is point
99 then 100 time steps later you've
reduced your you're sort of down
weighting everything by a factor of 1
over e and so on so but that's that's
day of using this discount factor and
now it's just worth looking at the
formulas we've shown so far and the one
way to interpret them is as multiplying
grad log probability times an estimate
of the advantage function so I haven't
defined the advantage function yet but
you can think of the advantage function
but here what I mean by this is that the
advantage estimate is just telling you
whether the acting was good or bad so
we're just multiplying grad log
probability times some scalar which is
an estimate of whether the action was
good or bad and in this case we're just
taking that
scaler to be the dis discounted sum of
following rewards - a baseline okay so
putting everything together that we've
shown so far what we get is this
so-called vanilla policy grading
algorithm and so the way this works is
iteration first collect a set of
trajectories by executing the current
policy and then at each time step we
compute the return the discounted return
which is this sum of future rewards down
weighted by discount factors and we
compute the advantage estimate which is
defined as this return minus the
baseline then we we refit the baseline
by doing this is just a nonlinear
regression problem so we can set up a
least-squares optimization where we
minimum we fit the baseline to their
insurance and then we update the policy
by taking a policy gradient but we
compute a policy gradient estimate which
is the sum of terms of the form grad log
probability times advantage and actually
there's a slightly modified version of
this which is sort of a more modern
version version which is compatible with
very efficient implementations is we've
called the advantage at predict
algorithm so there's this paper
asynchronous methods for deep
reinforcement learning which introduced
what's called the advantage actor
advantage actor critic asynchronous
advantage actor critic algorithm a3c so
that's so the asynchronous part doesn't
really matter here it's just sort of for
performance reasons but for what I'm
presenting here is what's called what
could be called the advantage actor
critic which is sort of the vanilla
policy grading algorithm but with some
like modifications that make it more
compatible with efficient implementation
so the way you it works is now instead
of collecting full trajectories you
collect paid days
said it like a certain fixed number of
time steps for each update so you you
have your agent and it acts for tea time
steps such as 20 time steps and and then
for each time step along that that
trajectory segment you compute the
return and where you cap it off with the
year with a estimate of the value
function at the end of the trajectory
and you compute the advantage function
also at each time step and so we're
going to use the return as a target for
the value function in a regression
problem and value function is synonymous
with the baseline if you're not that
familiar with it so so V here is can
also be thought of as the baseline B
that we were using in the previous slide
so here we we're going to use R as the
target value function at a as the
estimated advantage function and we just
set up this loss function which has
which has our policy gradient loss which
is grad log probability times advantage
and then also our value function
regression error and this can be plugged
into a stochastic gradient algorithm
such as that but this is exactly the
same thing we were doing before but it
just like something this is just a
version version that uses a fixed number
of time steps at once instead of using
collecting full trajectories and okay so
that's and even though this is very
simple and basic it's when you run it
for a really large number of time steps
you can get pretty impressive results
such as navigating a 3d maze just using
learning a policy which is a
convolutional neural network which
navigates the 3d maze using only pixels
as input so this was this was from
deepmind about last year from gladden he
and collaborators and I have a video
actually at that
so actually I'm out of time
so I just want to show a couple videos
just to sort of show what you can do
with these methods so the video from the
ABC paper which is navigating a 3d maze
using pixels in as input using exactly
this algorithm and I'll also show a
video of so I didn't get to this part of
the presentation but you can also so
there's also some methods you can do to
get more get more information from the
data you collect and also regulate your
so you can do a better update where
instead of just doing a grading update
you set up a trust region problem and
you you solve that
so you set up a little constrained
optimization problem that need to you do
an update on that and as you ends up
getting better sample efficiency and and
also sort of more reliability so I'm not
gonna what
oh yes yes I'll show the first video and
then so that's labeled one - a three C
and then the last and I also show the
for this - PPO which is sort of or
actually showed - - C RPO
which is which is learning to to run in
simulation which is based on this trust
region kind of algorithm which I didn't
have time to talk about so yeah please
show the the first video okay good and
then once that's done start the - - T
RPO video I can't see what you're
showing so just tell me when to start
okay cool
okay so okay so this is a video that
like collaborated collaborators and I
were working on learning to learning
locomotion controllers we're from
scratch where you just have this 3d this
broke up the three later getting the
input is just the joint angles and joint
velocities and so forth and the output
is is the joint torques and so it's a
pretty low level representation of
everything and it starts off just
falling over instantly but eventually it
it starts falling over a little bit more
slowly and and so on until finally it's
actually running and it can actually run
indefinitely long after it after
learning is complete and then you can
there's nothing in that algorithm
specific to running so you can also use
it on a four four legged creature and
you can also use it on learning how to
get up off the ground so we defined I
don't know if we've gotten up to that
part yet but we defined a reward
function which is something like
distance of your head from some target
height and then it'll learn how to do
some kind of ballistic motion with its
arms and get up off the ground and so
people have previously done
locomotion control so we weren't the
first person people to do that but
previous attempts have usually used much
more hand-coded representations where
you specify for example that you're
trying to place your feet left right
left right and you're just deterred your
algorithm your network is just
determining where to put your foot for
example whereas we were just we just had
a feed-forward network mapping from
observations to actions directly so oh
oh yeah so so this was a video produced
by my collaborator recently where it's
just like it's using so basically you've
got this guy running around and being
bump bar and in the head five bricks and
he still manages to get up off the
ground and he's running towards the red
ball so you see these red ball
randomly appearing so here your word
function is not just to run forward but
it's to run towards the ball and the
balls randomly appear so I mean when you
see this I think it becomes more
plausible you could actually get soccer
football sorry okay or something if you
really put these skills together so so
I'm pretty excited about what we can do
with that that's using as a slight
something called we call it proximal
policy optimization it's basically you
have it's like cross region policy
optimization but you use a soft
constraint instead of a hard constraint
and actually I'm going to put out a
paper on that in the next week or so so
you can check out so it'll be on the
archive in a few days so yeah I wish I
could tell you about more of this stuff
but we're out of time and it's late over
there so so hope you have your evening
[Applause]